[Music]
it's Monday morning [ __ ] you dare
enter this house it's the house that
reefer built [ __ ] Babe Ruth
science [ __ ] uncle Joey here Monday
the [ __ ] hate of May slinging victim
and given out dynamite stakes you
understand me the week is [ __ ] new
tell these [ __ ] to suck your
dick whatever happened last week out the
last week this week is a whole new week
you're coming at him with a whole new
attitude and you got some love plasma
and your nutsack ready to [ __ ] spread
on some of these [ __ ] face you
understand me
that's how we're rolling today it's a
beautiful day to be alive you got the
world by the balls
you only gonna get stopped you
[ __ ] is yourself you understand
me everything else is background music
you know why cuz I'm [ __ ] uncle
Joey's here ready to make your [ __ ]
day a lot better than what it was the
goal of the day is to make somebody's
day today even if you just make them
giggle for two [ __ ] seconds and take
that mind off whatever [ __ ] is going
on in the world right now cuz it's all
[ __ ] gotta do with you you still got
to get up in the morning smoke reefer
and go [ __ ] work and hustle like a
[ __ ] Savage so what do you give a
[ __ ] with draw up away oh my god this
party the other day gives a [ __ ] you
just taken [ __ ] hostages at this
point your goddamn life well we got some
tremendous we for today we got the
culture og from perennial as usual and
this one I can't even tell you what's in
that you understand that's how we're
rolling today podcast
eight o'clock tonight ready to rock
always on a Monday
but this reap is tremendous I've been up
since 7:00 right I gave the kid some
breakfast I smoked a couple [ __ ] bong
hits a little coffee and nicotine dump I
did a little stretching and now I'm
ready for the [ __ ] day what do I have
today I never put my balls in somebody's
[ __ ] mouth I gotta straighten people
out today but the most important person
I got a straight man today is myself
because it's [ __ ] Monday you
understand me I'll get tuned up and
carnage it's over put some blood in
these [ __ ] veins the tongue is
finally healing
thank you for your [ __ ] concerns and
notes that I go to a hospital three
times twice in LA I want some [ __ ]
Salt Lake if you went to the shows in
Salt Lake who loves you more than me
that's the last of the real Mohican
towns it reminds me of Aspen in 83
[ __ ] people don't know about it this
scared cousin of Mormons but a
small-time hustler like yourself can put
a [ __ ] Utah and take over that
[ __ ] City understand about you today
[ __ ] these other [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] who get got nothing to do with you
you still gotta get up in the morning
and [ __ ] stab a [ __ ] in the neck
don't forget set your dvrs tonight uncle
Joey's back on prime time CPS superior
doughnuts as ugly as fact and [ __ ] up
as I am I'm on the CBS tonight so if I
could do it did you imagine what you
could do you got a family you have no
felonies you were raised the right way
you don't do drugs can you imagine what
you could do you could take the [ __ ]
world over they could listen with what
you got you could [ __ ] tell people to
shut the [ __ ] up me I have two fellas
one more I do 23 years and then they
pour me back to Cuba you know saying
that I got to do periscope was really
Island I don't know how the Internet's
working that
it's gonna be [ __ ] toast beside that
what the [ __ ] were smoking another
bullish [ __ ] that's how we do it on a
Monday morning we leave the [ __ ]
house nice and [ __ ] stoned so we got
no excuses oh yeah
it's your lucky day you're feeling good
you're looking good your balls are
washed that's it and hopefully you like
Toshi said your [ __ ] nice and
[ __ ] clean too listen we do it right
on a Monday cuz if it ain't right on
Monday it's not gonna be right the rest
of the week so all that shit's
background music today's gotta be
correct by the tea to the [ __ ] doctor
and not the rest of the we could go to
[ __ ] you know that might know that I
smoke another ball of death here and
we'll continue what I day write your
goals do what you need to do to put it
[ __ ] together all right
Milwaukee I'm coming in [ __ ] heavy
heavy Friday night
mat full tron is opening for me and both
Milwaukee and [ __ ] Detroit full
charge that's how we do it we don't
wanna end up like dr. died with blood on
your head and [ __ ] tonight so [ __ ]
let's do it not that thou I doing too
bad he's in Hong Kong right now getting
this foot rub smoking opium he's got a
little [ __ ] 18 year old girls could
just bound on his shoulders Chinese
style he's just sitting there [ __ ]
thanks United see that why couldn't a
white dude think of that because they
wanted to beat up the bull up in Chinese
guy didn't think he knew kung fu he know
kung fu or the [ __ ] mind that's the
best powerful enough
my lungs feel fantastic I had a physical
on Wednesday I'm tip-top Magoo the HIV
disappeared you know I'm back [ __ ] so
anyway I love you [ __ ] don't
forget the church tonight eight o'clock
be there or be square
will it drop some knowledge on your ass
and I have a great week you know uncle
Joey loves you from the [ __ ] bottom
of my [ __ ] heart what are you
[ __ ] that had nothing so you guys
got to attack out of respect for uncle
Joey you follow me I'm [ __ ] stoned I
can't be smoking four pipe loads of
[ __ ] a 40 in the morning what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me they don't have to put
me in some [ __ ] thing I have to put
me nowhere I'm right where I wanna be
stoned loaded and ready to get my dick
sucked and I suggest you do the same
uncle Joey loves you see you tonight
eight o'clock won't take no [ __ ] from
nobody understand me [ __ ] I'm Carrie
they didn't came out my till our bingo
don't forget superior doughnuts tonight
I don't know what time in your [ __ ]
timezone stay black